the houston texans losing one of their
best receivers for the rest of the
season
will fuller suspended six games for a
ped
violation and look p.e.d violations
don't happen as often as i believe
ped violations are actually occurring
they do they do a good job of staying a
step ahead of the testing but every once
in a while
someone gets popped it would be naive to
assume that players given the money
that's at stake
aren't doing everything they can to stay
on the football field
and recover quickly from injuries will
fuller who's had a history of injuries
having a pretty good season making an
impact for the texans now he's gone and
deshawn watson basically is left with
brandon cooks and randall cobb now that
they've cut kenny stills
yeah it was probably great for the
packers that they didn't trade for will
fuller right
and because they used to spend it for
the rest of year becomes a free agent in
the off season so not good timing for
will fuller not good timing for desean
watson who's having a heck of a year
even if it's buried under everything
else as bad as the texans are
he's playing great and has stepped up to
the next level but now he's going to
have to do it without kenny stills and
without will fuller good luck with that
desean watson and
i i haven't seen enough of the details
yet because this is all happening while
we're on the air with will fuller
but if his appeals have ended and the
six games begins now and i assume that
it does
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports